so
i spoke to yaran brook about
objectivism and iron rand
he uh he kind of argued he highlighted
difference between capitalism and
anarchism
as around the topic of violence
and the that
having government
be the sort of the the the negative way
to say it is like having a monopoly on
violence
but basically being the arbiter of or
the the people that making sure that
violence doesn't get out of hand
that would 2020 show that yep the
government's great at that
yep well what what's okay
with without this is him with a straight
face making that argument good work here
on
all right well can you with a straight
face argue
for the idea that in anarchism
violence would not get out of hand sure
for one thing
uh if your worst argument against one of
my little quotes is
what are presented as the strongest
arguments against anarchism are
inevitably description of the stratus
quo so the argument is under anarchism
you know you'd have warlords you know
killing people
and then you'd have uh you know
whoever's strongest gets to just take
over a neighborhood
well we have that now we saw that the
police
are perfectly comfortable disarming the
population
and then when they try to protect
themselves are punished they're
we're happy to stand down you can't you
can only have that happen
if you have a monopoly if they're like
let's suppose you had uh television
stations right
and cbs said you know what we're not
gonna broadcast
cool you don't broadcast we're gonna
watch any of these other channels so
the problem with having monopoly is
everyone has to be dependent on this
issue what's amazing about minikism
which objectivists are
is they will argue that government is
really really bad
at everything it does and it touches
therefore
it has to be in charge of the most
important stuff well that's not
there for but but there is a thing
that's fundamentally different than all
the other things but ron brooke also
said
that no government has ever this is on
your show
has ever worked in the way he's
proposing now objectivism
ein rand's philosophy is based on
objective reality and what she
posited is you look and study the facts
of nature stack
that's reality and induce things
accordingly and
she very much regards herself as part of
the aristotelian tradition
as opposed to the pl plaintiff's
tradition where the idea
precedes reality and the idea is more
real than what we see around us
so what he's saying is all the data
according to him contradicts his
argument
but still he's going to make this
imaginary government
that has never existed and there's no
evidence that it can
exist um let's talk about objective law
to have access to the legal system which
is something we want
even just in terms of selling disputes
when you have a government monopoly
it's going to be more expensive more
difficult for poor people
the cost of hiring a lawyer is more
expensive than hiring a surgeon
you can't say with a straight face this
is the only way or the best way
okay so and the other thing is the
argument for objectivism they have this
stupid
against anarchism they have this stupid
claim it's like what if
you know you're a member of one security
company and i'm a member of another
and we have a dispute and one shows up
the door what happens now
as if this is some insuperable argument
well we have that on earth
every country is in a state of anarchism
regarding every other country we don't
have a world government
so what happens if a canadian
kills an american in mexico i have no
idea i bet you don't have an idea
what i'm sure of is that system has been
worked out ahead of time between the
three countries
and it's been worked out in such a way
that you and i don't have to reinvent
the wheel
same thing with cell phone companies if
i'm on sprint you're on metropcs and i
call you
who pays does sprint pay you do they
split the difference
first of all there's no objective way
that one has to work but the thing is
companies who have auto accidents
they have arbitrage all the time like if
i run into you they work it out
and it never reaches our um our desk
so the only thing that cops are good at
is keeping people at any government
monopoly is forcing people to be their
customers by keeping them unsafe
okay there's a few things i'd like to
say there
to just explore some of these ideas so
one
in terms of canadian new mexico and so
on that it does
something has been worked out perhaps
not perhaps don't say perhaps you know
for sure
that if something there's a point i'm
trying to make so let's say for sure
it's been worked out
there is a there was a point in history
where it wasn't worked out
like to to to work to come to a place of
stability there has to first be some
instability so you when you first
like for every kind of situation
they're like dispute over space like who
gets to own mars
that kind of thing sure there's a first
for it and then
these different competing institutions
will have to
figure it out and so there's the concern
with anarchism i think
or with any kind of interaction what you
said
brilliantly that there's an anarchism
relative to the
there's no one world government right uh
alex jones enters the chat but uh
the there's an insta because the fear is
that there's going to be an
instability that's that that doesn't
converge towards some stable place
that is not the fear that is the goal
under iran's philosophy
markets have something what they always
talk about as being creatively
destructive
which means you look at something that's
been happening for a very long time
every generation every innovator starts
chipping away at it
he finds better ways marginal
improvement or marginal and or doesn't
work and he goes broke
when government tries to implement
improvement we all have to suffer the
consequences when an innovator does it's
a huge asymmetry
if it hurts it only hurts him if it
succeeds he becomes rich and we all
profit as a consequence but the fear of
anarchism i think is that
it will be non-creative destruction
it'll be just destruction
right it's it's not like the instability
let's give you there's no stability is
one of these words that sounds objective
but has no real meaning
what field has stability if you had
let's suppose you want stability
relationships
yeah let's talk about medicine stability
means we're not going to invent new
diseases or new treatments
right if you mean stability in terms of
a baseline
of security we have that already
very few relationships turn violent
under an anarchist system
look at it right now where if you look
at a bar
full of drunken young males full of
testosterone
if you look at a hotel where everyone
is not native to the area those are both
far safer than the places that the
government has taken upon
itself to protect you the parks the
alleyways
the streets the subways we have right
now a comparison
of which is better at keeping people
safe and it's
very obvious that when something is
private and under someone's control
and there would be layers of there'd be
more police but they wouldn't be a
government monopoly
the store would have someone the street
would have someone and you'd have your
own personal security that would be
attached to your phone
having security as a function of
geography
as opposed to a function of you as an
individual is
a landline technology in a post-cell
phone world so
you think it's possible to have
psychologically speaking as an
individual among the masses to have a
sense of security
even there's even though there's not a
centralized thing at the bottom of the
whole thing so like
there's not a set of laws that are
enforced based on geography like we have
nations now you can have a set of laws
that are enforcing some kind of
emergent agreed-upon way so like
basically i want to go to a hotel
and trust that i'll be able to get a
room and nobody's going to break down
the door
and i don't know but you have to take
all my vodka
let's let's take a different way if you
were worried about a hotel having bed
bugs that's not something that
government's involved in
what mechanic and that's not an
unrealistic concern
are there mechanisms right now that you
can undertake to make sure that's not
the case
yes so it would be the same thing with i
want to make sure
i go to hotel that has security
it will be exactly the same thing and
here's another example kosher food
people who keep kosher jews who keep
kosher their food has to be prepared in
a certain way
it has to meet higher rabbinical
standards right if you look at food
it will have that certification the k
this and there's even competition there
there's the k
and there's a stricter u letter people
don't notice it because they're looking
for it right
you would have companies certifying
different locales
for their level of security and it would
take an
hour to have an app that would just like
when you have toll roads right
that would tell you you're approaching
an unsafe area you're not going to be
covered by us
or and you could have it color-coded
very easily we could do this
today but the thing is you're exactly
correct but
there's an assumption of you're already
in a okay you can give me a different
word than stability but you're already
in a place
where the forces of the market or
whatever can
operate right the worry is like
initially
you might not have enough stability to
where you can choose
one place over the other versus based on
the security that they provide
we already have different types of
security here because we have federal
government
we have state governments and we have
local governments
so and and these often contradict each
other
so the idea of the implausibility of
having different security
companies and having it be unstable or
impossible
we already have a very rough example of
it happening in real life but
all of it started this is what this like
the idea of especially with euron
is like it all started with government
monopoly of violence saying like
now kids don't let violence get out of
hand
so like we had a civil war where half
the country was slaughtered
that's the display of the government not
having a monopoly
on the violence right it's like it's
it had such a monopoly on the violence
in the north that it could draft people
to fight others that they didn't even
care but there's a south so it's like
it's a
it's a it's the government splitting
okay it's because this is giant iceberg
like splitting it's
it's the the argument is that you would
have something like a civil war much
more often under
anarchism but that's that's that's first
of all if you had a civil war
much more often we don't have that with
car companies right there's no car
company that says i refuse
to pay you or whatever uh that's not
violence sorry to interrupt but
like uh and i'm playing this it isn't
that i'll totally finish it is violence
because if i'm a company
and i'm saying that my cars can run over
yours
with no consequences this is a rough
analog that's
why has that not happened now in terms
of having security system
if i am free just like switching cell
phone to go from one provider to
another and this one company as part of
its payment doesn't
want fifty dollars a month a hundred
dollars a month wants my son
i'm not going to be a member of the
security company unless
in that case we're dealing with
something like a pearl harbor or for
innovation where it's like all hands on
deck
let's go by evidence how many places do
you have
evidence of that there you can have at a
large scale
well it's absolutely a large scale
because it feels like
once you don't know the person what
about ebay
ebay is an example of anarchism practice
i am selling something to someone whose
name i don't even know in a country that
is nowhere approximate to me
and ebay acts as the arbiter sometimes i
don't get the money after i get screwed
over but that's
far less than the taxation that i have
to give to the federal government it's a
great point
but it's in the space of finance if i
could
if on ebay you could also commit
violence
theft is no if
yeah if you give me 10 grand for a car
and i don't deliver anything you've
stolen 10 grand for me yes but it's
there's something uniquely problematic
to being stabbed or shot the reason
you're
stabbed or shot is because the
government despite its contract
is refusing to allow second amendment
rights to be
implemented among the citizenry and the
people who are
making that the case are the cops they
are the ones who are the traitors of the
constitution and should be regarded as
such
whereas private companies are far more
amenable to market pressures than the
state is
it's a strong argument but um
let's actually just briefly mention the
scale thing
why why don't you think we should talk
about scale like
because if you had anarchism just in
vermont or just in brooklyn
well fine the people make the argument
you need anarchism whereas china is
going to invade
but that's like saying what like this
like do these little countries don't
exist does san salvador not exist some
of them are violent some of them are not
but the point is they're not all at a
moment's notice about to be invaded
kuwait's an example of this
kuwait was invaded by iraq and very
quickly all the big countries who are
interested
in having your stability safe space got
involved and and kicked him out of
kuwait
if you had this company that was waging
more in the population
it seems quite likely that the other
organization would get together put a
stop to this
because they're not a position to
provide the services security to their
customers
okay all this is brilliant but didn't
you just say
that we are actually in a state of
anarchism
relative to other countries yes so isn't
this what emerges
this is this is what aren't we actually
living in a state of anarchism
where we all have agreed i haven't
agreed to anything so like
the basic criticism you have is like
you're born
on a land geographical land geographical
area
and you're forced to have signed a bunch
of stuff
just by being born right a good place so
so really you could if you could just
much easier
choose right which space of ideas
you uh associated with right that would
be actually a state of anarchism
yes and you could have
like a military that you sign up with
sure
and you're certainly not putting people
in prison to get raped
because they're selling drugs yeah
uh and you're certainly not allowing
everyone else on the street who wants to
be there
you